good afternoon and welcome to today's
downing street coronavirus briefing and
i'm joined by deputy chief medical
officer
professor jonathan van tam and by dr
susan hopkins from
phe and nhs test and trace and since
we spoke on friday i'm absolutely
delighted that we've reached the
milestone
of vaccinating 20 million people across
the uk it is a magnificent achievement
first slide please and as of yesterday
20 million 275 451 people
have received a jab and i want to pay
tribute to all the teams
involved across the whole of the uk
who've been delivering
the largest and fastest vaccination
program
in british history and that we've been
able to do this
and that we've been able to move so much
faster than any
other similar sized nation has depended
on a
huge number of people it is not an
accident it's
down to insight and hard work for the
last year
this team has shared a common mission
which is to deliver us
a vaccine as fast as safely
possible we've got used to saying thank
you to people who've made it
happen but i just want to call out a
couple in particular
firstly the regulator the mhra
who have remained tough and rigorous
throughout
yet flexible so that it's safety not
bureaucracy
that they focus on and they have proved
themselves to be in my view
the best medical regulator in the world
and we
are all very grateful next the vaccines
task force
their combination of academic excellence
with private sector entrepreneurialism
and civil service grip has forged
a team of remarkable capability
which is a model for how governments can
get stuff done
in the future the scientists the
pharmaceutical companies the armed
forces everyone involved in the delivery
effort from the leadership of the nhs
through to every local volunteer and
you the british people for sticking to
the rules
and for the remarkable enthusiasm to get
a jab which makes me really proud
recent figures show 94
of those eligible have said that they
either have had a jab or will get a jab
when their call comes
94 and this is so
important because each and every jab
makes us all safer
every time a friend sends me a message
with a picture of them having had their
jab
and this happens to me a lot i know that
we're all one step
safer safer and we're all one step
closer to returning to normality so it
is fantastic the enthusiasm that people
are showing
and we've still got a long way to go so
let's stick at it
today we have some new data to show on
the
effectiveness of the vaccine both its
real world effect
that we can now see in the data and
some new analytical research that we're
publishing
that shows how it's saving lives and
this
is being published in a paper by public
health england and others
right now first let's look at the real
world
data next slide please
if you look at the number of new cases
as we described on friday the number of
new cases is falling
but the rate of decline has slowed this
shows
how we all need to keep sticking to the
rules
let's not blow it now however next slide
please
the number of hospitalizations is
falling faster
even better among the age groups who
were vaccinated
first so the older age groups the fall
in hospitalizations
is faster than in the younger age groups
who are still yet to get a jab
this is a sign that the vaccine is
working
next slide please but where you can
really see it
is in the data on deaths
we can see that the number of deaths
each day is thankfully falling
much much faster than in the first peak
and again as you can see from this slide
it's falling faster in the over 80s who
got the job first
than in the under 80s final slide please
and taken together this difference in
the data between older and younger
groups shows a vaccine gap and you can
just see it starting to emerge here
over february this is a gap between
the rate of decline in older and younger
groups where the older groups were
obviously vaccinated first
and you're seeing that their the rate of
decline
in terms of the number of people dying
each day is going faster
amongst the over 80s and this shows in
the real world
across the uk right now that the vaccine
is helping
both to protect the nhs and to save
lives
and these real world effects are backed
up by some exciting new data
that shows that a single shot of either
the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine or of the pfizer vaccine works
against severe infection among the over
70s
with a more than 80 reduction
in hospitalizations this is extremely
good news
in fact the detailed data show that the
the protection that you get from
catching covid
35 days after a first jab
is even slightly better for the oxford
jab
than for pfizer albeit both results
are clearly very strong and professor
van tam's going to set out more details
in a moment these results may also help
to explain
why the number of covert admissions to
intensive care units
among people over 80 in the uk have
dropped to single figures
in the last couple of weeks which is
something i know that we all welcome
this is seriously encouraging it shows
the power of science
and what it means for you is that when
the call comes
get the jab the evidence shows that it
will protect
you and protect others and i can
formally announce that we're now
inviting
the over 60s to be vaccinated all part
of our national effort
to ensure everybody is offered the
vaccine
every adult by the end of july
to do that and to make sure our vaccine
program is always kept up to date
we are making sure that the program has
the funds that it needs to do all of
this incredible work
at the budget on wednesday the
chancellor will set out
1.65 billion pounds worth of new
government funding to reinforce our
vaccine rollout across all parts of the
uk
as more of us are protected against the
virus we can gradually replace the
safety that comes from the restrictions
that we have to impose
with the safety that comes from the jab
and part of that funding will go towards
further vaccine testing and development
to make sure we are as fast
and effective in developing the next
generation of covert vaccines
including vaccines against new variants
as we were with the existing ones and
there's a huge amount of under
work underway to ensure that we can
develop
vaccines against variants as fast
as safely possible finally i want to
turn
to a different subject at the six cases
of the variant of concern
that was first identified in manaus in
brazil
that we have identified here in the uk
three in scotland and three in england
we know that five of these people
quarantined at home
as they were legally required to do
we've been in contact with them
and their families and we're grateful to
them for understanding the seriousness
of the situation
we're putting in place surge testing in
south gloucestershire as a precaution
and i urge everyone to remain vigilant
one of the six completed a test but did
not
successfully complete contact details
and we're therefore
asking anyone who took a test on the
12th or 13th of february
but hasn't received the result back to
please get in touch
by calling 119 in england wales
or northern ireland or in scotland 0300
303 2713 and dr
hopkins will give more information about
this effort in a moment
we identified these cases thanks to the
uk's advanced sequencing capabilities
we know about them because of the work
of nhs test and trace
and scientists around the world are now
working hard to get ahead of some of
these new
variants looking at how much a third
vaccine dose
could tackle these evolving mutations if
it's necessary
much as we tackle mutations from flu
each year but for now tackling this
disease rests with
every single one of us it's important to
remember that no matter what variant it
is
covid spreads in the same way through
social contact between people
the steps that we can all take to stop
its spread are the same
to stay at home to take vital steps
like hands face and space and make sure
we observe the basics
letting fresh air in and keeping to the
rules on social
distancing and that's how we can keep
ourselves safe
and protect the people around us and if
we do that
as surely as spring follows winter
there will be brighter days ahead i'm
now going to turn to
dr hopkins to set out more about the p1
variant
and then to professor van tan on more
details
of this excellent research into the
impact of the vaccine
susan thank you secretary of state as
has widely been reported this weekend we
identified six cases
of a new variant of concern in the uk
three cases in england
and three in scotland this variant
called p1
has been identified widely in minas
brazil
and also in other countries across the
world we are tracking it closely
because it shares some important
mutations with the variant first
identified in south africa
such as e484k and n501y
unusual names i understand these and
other mutations
are associated with reduced impact of
antibodies against the virus in
laboratory experiments
the current vaccines have not yet been
studied against this variant
and we will need to wait further
clinical and trial data to understand
the vaccine effectiveness
against this variant in the meantime
it is important that we track cases of
this new variant
as closely as possible in order to limit
its spread in the uk
of the cases found two are from a single
household in the south gloucester area
one of these individuals traveled back
from brazil and has subsequently
isolated effectively at home
the household developed symptoms shortly
afterwards and household members
went forward got tested the sample was
sequenced through our
our sequencing laboratories and reported
to be this p1 variant
as the secretary of state has said we
are doing additional surge testing
in parts of south gloucestershire as a
highly precautionary measure
and we urge people in that part of the
country to come forward for testing
i would like to stress though that these
individuals have
followed all of the current protocols in
terms of self-isolation
both on their return from the uk but
also
after they've received positive test
results and developed symptoms
we're also contacting individuals who
were on the swiss air flight
lx 318 traveling from zurich
into london on the 10th of february to
provide public health advice and to test
them
and their households more than 90
percent of the flight have already been
contacted through the details they left
on the passenger locator form
if you were a passenger on that flight
and have not been contacted
please call 0-117-450-3174
to arrange a test for you and your
household contacts
there is also a third unlinked case this
individual did not complete their test
registration required
so follow-up details were not available
to the test and trace teams
this is an extremely rare event probably
less than 1 000 of individuals who have
a test
through the community testing services
we cannot trace in this way
but we know this is more frequent about
0.3 percent in those that do home tests
or have tests through the surge testing
service
we're in the process of doing everything
we can to track down this individual
who we believe would have taken the test
on the 12th or 13th of january or
february
we're especially looking for individuals
who may have taken a test through surge
testing
those tests that the local authorities
hand out door-to-door
and haven't managed to complete their
online form to either complete their
online form
or call one of the numbers that i'm
going to tell you about
these numbers are 119 in england and
0-300-303-2713
in scotland as soon as possible thank
you
thank you very much dr hopkins and now
i'm going to turn to professor van tam
to set out more details on the
uh uh on the good news in terms of the
impact
of the vaccines thank you secretary of
state and
um a few moments ago
public health england with partners
from across the four devolved nations
of the uk um published a new report
summarizing vaccine effectiveness to
date
as part of the the england and
england program now
thank you for bearing with us because it
has taken a while
for that signal to stabilize so we have
enough confidence to
give you some data but equally
it is still remarkably fast and a credit
to our public health agencies
that they've been able to do it in this
very short period of time
since our vaccination program began and
i particularly
want to mention jamie lopez bernal
mary ramsey nick andrews and their
colleagues
who have done really an enormous amount
of hard work
to get us to where we are today in terms
of our data understanding
so the data i'm going to lay out for you
are all
data pertaining to vaccine effectiveness
after the first dose of vaccine
and you have to be very careful about
the outcome measures that you are
describing and therefore i'll go through
them
very carefully the first outcome measure
is outcome against infections
defined in this case as people who
are ill with symptoms and who come
forwards and take
a positive covid test and the data
are for individuals aged 70 years of age
and over and for both vaccines
we see vaccine effectiveness against
illness after the first dose
of approximately 60 percent
that was measured 28 to 34 days
after the vaccine had been given but in
the case of the
pfizer vaccine that effect is seen to be
sustained
into the 35 day plus time bracket
for astrazeneca in the 35 day plus time
bracket
there is an early sign that that might
still be increasing
to around 70 percent but the
confidence intervals on that are very
wide
and that is a less certain figure but
the figure i
can be certain of is 60 percent
effectiveness
against illness
now obviously there are still
unfortunately because no vaccine is a
hundred percent effective
people who become ill despite having had
that first dose of vaccine
but if you look at the then reductions
in hospitalization
that are occurring on top
in those people who still become
infected
and you add that to the fact that people
who are not infected
can't by definition be hospitalized with
covid
what that brings you to is an overall
effect
for both vaccines in public health terms
that they are now preventing 80 percent
of um reducing the likelihood of
hospitalization
by 80 percent after one dose
so that's the second outcome the
hospitalizations data
and the third outcome is mortality and
because of the fact that mortality takes
longer to measure
deaths unfortunately from covid take
longer to occur
after hospitalizations at this point
we only have data for the pfizer vaccine
where the likelihood of mortality
is being reduced by 85
in those over 70 year olds so
that's really the summary um there's a
lot more detail
in the phe paper which is online
but i think you'll agree with me that
although these data pertain
just to the 70 plus age group at the
moment
and our vaccine program moves on
with really significant pace now
as we move into the lower age groups it
shows us gives us those first glimpses
of how if we are patient and we
give this vaccine program time to have
its full effect
it is going to hopefully take us into a
very different
world in the next few months but we have
to be patient
we have to push on with the vaccine
program
and most importantly when you are called
for your place in the vaccine queue it's
important that you come forwards
and have that first dose and when called
for your second dose
and some people will be being called
back quite soon now for their second
doses
to come forwards for that too thank you
secretary steve
great stuff professor van tam thank you
very much indeed uh
our first questions are from members of
the public and the first by video
is from claire from selby
why is there such disparity across the
country in accessing the vaccine
in my local area group 7 is being
vaccinated before group 6
and i have fit and healthy friends age
60 who've had the jab
other areas are starting over 50 soon
why are group 6 the clinically
vulnerable with chronic ill health being
left behind
and should the vaccines not be dispensed
equally
thanks very much claire so we are
working incredibly hard to get these
vaccines out and making sure that we
both deliver according to the order set
out by the
joint committee on vaccinations and
immunizations
and also do that in a way that doesn't
lead to any vaccine being wasted
for instance we know that the fisa jab
has to be used within
a few days of it coming out of the
freezer
so the vaccine centers are allowed if
the vaccine is otherwise going to be
wasted
to make sure that it's used on a on a
reserve list which might include people
who are from the next category down so
that does
happen occasionally we're essentially
balancing the need for
speed with the need for sticking by the
the rank ordering what i can tell you
though
is that we are getting through all those
groups and we're running at
around half a million a day just under
on average
over the last week and this means that
if you are in group six
and you haven't yet been called you
won't have to wait for long
because we're really rattling through
that group as we speak
um so i of course i understand the the
concern here
it is a matter of balancing the
practical operational need for speed
and some flexibility with trying to
stick by the
the rank ordering um jv team unless you
have anything to do with that
thank you thanks very much claire a very
important question i appreciate it
uh next question is from aleister from
norwich
concerning the government's dates are
hopefully reintroducing public freedoms
are there any specific numbers of daily
cases
deaths or hospital admissions that they
feel we have to be below
in order to guarantee those freedoms if
so what are they
great question alastair the answer is no
there are not specific
thresholds and the reason for that is
that the prime minister set out
four tests and all four matter but some
of them can't be quantified
in numbers so the four tests include of
course that hospitalizations
and deaths are coming down also that
there isn't a surge in cases that might
risk hospitalizations going
up in the future also that the vaccine
program
is rolling out well and finally that
there isn't a new variant of control
of concern that puts all this at risk
and so the challenge is that
we have to balance all four of these
metrics
and the some of them can be quantified
like the number of hospitalizations and
deaths
but others can't like the impact of a a
variant of concern because it depends on
the nature of that variant
so that's why we haven't put precise
numbers on it
but we make a judgment based on these
four
uh these four tests as to whether we can
take each step
in the roadmap when the time comes
thanks aleister
next question is from laura koonsberg at
the bbc laura
thank you very much indeed secretary of
state um someone carrying the brazilian
variant was able to
disappear weeks after the variant was
first detected because the government
hadn't yet got round to introducing
quarantine hotels
do you believe that that delay will have
put people at risk
and professor van tam if i can ask you
about the very um
effective news about the vaccine which
sounds very impressive
in the real world how would you describe
the impact that these kinds of results
suggest the vaccine might have and what
kind of difference
could that make in the weeks to come to
what we're all experiencing
uh thanks laura two very important
questions the answer to your first is no
we had already quarantined in place
and in fact we'd already put in place a
ban on direct travel from
brazil and also that if those who aren't
either citizens or resident here
couldn't come
and all the evidence is that the five
cases that we
know about followed those quarantine
rules
and that i hope is very reassuring to
people and
there is no evidence that the sixth case
and did not follow those
quarantine rules um we need to obviously
get in contact with the person in
question also this positive test was on
the 12th or 13th of february we think uh
and that was obviously over two weeks
ago and we haven't seen any further
uh knock-on transmissions
in the data that we obviously monitor
very very closely
and we now we now
sequence around a third of all of the
positive
tests so all of that points to
the work that's that's been done and the
system that was in place
uh having managed to uh control this
um but obviously since then we've
introduced further
and stricter measures the hotel
quarantine as you say
uh to uh to strengthen this system
further
uh in answer to your second question
i'll go straight to jay
to professor van tan yeah thanks for the
question laura
so um we've given first doses now
to more than 20 million people on the
jcvi
priority groups but we need to remember
that that still means
there are another 15 million people
roughly who need their first dose
and then it will be important to go back
progressively as we go through from now
really to give second doses
so it is still all going to take time
until we can apply the results that i've
described to you
in a more generalized way in the
population
but in time i expect the vaccine to
lower levels of disease across the
country
i expect it to reduce the likelihood
because we're starting from the elderly
and the most vulnerable
that infections that are present can get
into
the older and more vulnerable population
and i expect for the individuals who
have been vaccinated
even if they come across the virus
and even if they are infected
with the virus i expect the likelihood
of them suffering severe consequences
not to be eliminated but to be lessened
over time in other words the ratio of
mild cases to severe cases
should increase in favor of milder cases
as time goes by so there's a lot to look
forwards to it's very tempting to just
go
right we've seen the results that means
the problems fixed
the problem isn't fixed yet but we
definitely have identified
a way of fixing the problem and the
early data
show us how to do that and where to
advance from here
thanks very much indeed anything to add
susan
next question from romillyweeks at itv
romney
health secretary you've said that one of
the ways to stop the spread of this new
variant is to stay at home and yet
you're about to open schools and start
the process of
unlocking how likely is it that this new
variant could derail that process and if
i could ask
dr hopkins as well what is the
likelihood that there are
already many more than six cases of the
new variant
in the uk and the prime minister has
said today that there's no evidence
that the existing vaccines are not
effective against the new variant
how confident are you that they are
effective
thanks very much romney three vital
questions the first one
on schools we do not think that there's
any need to change the approach on
schools for monday because of this
new variant and the reason we think that
is that
five of in five of the six cases um
we have been in contact with them three
in scotland where of course public
health scotland takes the lead and
two in england in south gloucestershire
where public health england
have take the lead and they've been in
contact with these cases
and we have a high degree of confidence
that they follow quarantine um
as they are they were legally required
to do
in the case of the sixth case of course
we're
we as you know we're trying to track
down uh this
uh individual um but we also have not
seen any further
community spread and so whilst
obviously it's something that we should
be all vigilant
about and it reinforces the need for
people to follow the rules
as they are now it doesn't change our
assessment of
the of the roadmap right now not least
because our goal
is to contain uh this
uh transmission to just these six people
but
we will obviously be uh be looking out
for that very very carefully
yeah i would just add so we've sequenced
almost a 150
000 uh cases of this infection since
this
2021. these are the only six cases that
we've identified
we've also working with both the ons and
react studies
where they get a representative
proportion of the population sequenced
and we have not found the
any p1 cases in that that's all very
reassuring but we're still
on guard and increasing the proportion
of the cases that get sequenced on a
week-by-week basis
uh and clearly we will manage and look
to see if there's any other cases
in the community that's why we want this
individual to come forward
so we can ensure that their contacts
are tested that we review and look at
everything about this case
and can find out whether there are any
associated cases that need any further
work done to them
thanks very much romney and the next
question from thomas
more at sky secretary of state you know
there is this missing case but not
who or where or whether they
self-isolated
how is it that after two months of a
tough lockdown and just one week before
it starts to lift such a concerning new
variant
has been allowed to slip through the net
and professor van tam
level with the british public is there
any prospect of a foreign holiday this
summer when new variants are crossing
our borders
and there's still no vaccine with
inbuilt universal protection
against the evolving virus thanks thomas
well
i i see it the other way around it's
because of the extraordinary
capability of nhs test and trace that
we've been able to identify
these cases and in particular there is a
high chance that the identification of
the sixth
case came through the surge testing that
we put in
around communities where we were
previously looking for
for other variants of concern and we
don't know that for sure
but without the huge surveillance
that we have in terms of the testing
capability
and then the ability to sequence that we
wouldn't know about this
and by sequencing now around 30
of cases that means that we do have a
very good
survey to be able to spot uh variants of
concern like this but as you say
it is critical that people continue to
follow
the rules because that limits the spread
of new
variants in the same way that it limits
the spread of the existing
uh variant that is the what infects
most people in the country thankfully
with decreasing rates
susan i would just like to add that
sometimes it's it's really important
that
people may have got the test and then
not realized how to complete it or may
have lost their
their form to complete it 119 is
standing by in england
and also the scottish number is
available on the website so we are
imploring people to come forward if they
haven't got their test results
and we will help you find and reconnect
you with that test results
and therefore be able to stop any
transmission
thanks very much sarah bosley from the
guardian
thank you very much minister um so we
know that
the p1 virus obviously brazil is on the
red list of countries where people have
to quarantine as a result
of coming back but um labour is saying
that the p1 variants also been found
in germany the pharaoh islands italy
japan
republic of korea and the usa and none
of those
are on the red list so doesn't this mean
that
the uk's borders are in fact incredibly
porous and the red lists are
not the way to go about this since
variants can travel so easily
and secondly can i just ask you about
the very positive news from
phe about the vaccines and the
astrological vaccine in particular
do you think minister that this could
actually put paid to the skepticism
we've seen in europe about this vaccine
well thank you very much i'll answer
those two and then i'll ask jvt to
answer the previous question from
uh thomas moritz sky which i um i i cut
you off before you're about to
to answer that so um the first point is
that
the proportion of cases that are
variants of concern
in some other countries like germany are
exceptionally low
in the same way that the proportion of
cases here that are variants of concern
are exceptionally low
but there are some other countries like
brazil and
south africa where the variance of
concern
is the dominant variant and that is a
material consideration in terms of the
uh the the red list but what i'd say
further to that is
home quarantine is required for
everybody
and we have a requirement for a
pre-departure test
and then a test at day two and day eight
so we have these strong
safeguards against the uh
against these variants that are in place
uh that are in place now
um on the second question i hope that
people
uh look at the data that we've published
today
and see the rigor of the science and
read from that the same as i read from
it which is that
both of the vaccines that are in the use
in the uk
right now are extremely effective
after one dose there is some further
evidence in the paper
of further effectiveness after two doses
and that's yet more good news and and
there
are on some measures there are signs
that the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine is slightly more effective
than the pfizer vaccine but the fisa
vaccine on these data is also
extremely effective so i absolutely hope
that
right around the world people study
these data
and understand what they mean which is
that
getting the oxford astrazeneca jab or
getting
the pfizer jab is the right thing to do
and it could save your life
jvt yeah thank you so i'll go back to
just
before i answer add to that um sarah
i'll just go back to
thomas moore's question he asked me to
level with um
level with him and and the british
people about summer holidays and
you know look i think we are still as
you can see from
today's news um we are still in a zone
of great uncertainty
about what the virus will do next
on top of that many of the vaccination
programs
in europe which is a place where we
frequently go on holiday abroad
are running behind ours and clearly
whether we can go on holiday abroad to
places such as europe depends upon
what other countries will say and do
in terms of foreign tourism so
that's the best i can do to level with
you i'm not going to give you a firm
answer because
i genuinely don't think there is one at
this point
i think i would just say that there has
to be great uncertainty
at the moment on the point about
the astrazeneca vaccine and non-adoption
by many countries
in terms of its use in the over 65
population that was driven by the fact
that there were relatively small amounts
of data on the over 65s in
the clinical trials available at that
point in time
for the az vaccine and our
technical advisory committee the jcvi um
took a view which i share that it was
not
immunologically plausible that the
vaccine would work
up to uh in the in the age range 18 to
um you know to 55 years of age which is
um a lot of where a lot of where the
data ran out
and then kind of not work in those older
age groups we
took a view that it almost certainly
would work the phe data
have clearly vindicated that approach
today and um you know i'm
not here to criticize other countries
but to say that i
think in time the data emerging from our
program
will speak for itself and other
countries will
doubtless be very interested in it
thank you sir professor van tam very uh
diplomatic
um i i just add one other thing that
it's important to read
uh from this data which is that the data
do also support the clinician's
view the advice to us ministers which we
took
that the appropriate dosing regime is 12
weeks
apart in order to save the most lives
uh because the um the reduction of
hospitalizations by
more than eighty percent is a uh
is a very very good uh very very good
sign
um thank you very much uh sarah next
question is mesa hall
from the express uh thank you very much
secretary of state a question to
professor vantam and dr hopkins about
masks
and people in some parts of the world
have taken to wearing two masks
joe biden has been seen double masking i
just wanted
have you seen any evidence that suggests
double masking is a good idea and would
you recommend it
and uh secretary of state um israel like
the uk has had a very fast
vaccine roll out but there have been
concerns that significantly fewer people
come forward for a second dose
have you seen a similar thing happening
here and what are you doing to make sure
that people do get the two doses that
they need
thanks very much mesa double masking
so so i think what we know is that the
the more layers you have the better
and so that we recommend at least two
layers in the uk
and ideally three layers in a vaccine
and a vaccine
three layers in a mask and that is
really important to reduce the
viral transmission both from you to
others and from others to you
we have got a face masks and face
coverings
advisory group who meet on a regular
basis and look at new and emerging
evidence
and the u.s has looked at some of that
evidence as well
we are in an ongoing discussion about
what to do next but we think
one mask that has more than two layers
in it
is currently effective for the vast
majority of the population
uh thanks very much anything to add
nothing to add on that thank you
on the point about israel um first the
first thing i'd say is that we have seen
this vaccine gap emerging in the israeli
data
as well and it's very reassuring to see
the same
uh impressive results from the from the
vaccine
in israel as well as uh now here in the
uk
uh in terms of second doses um i have
heard those
reports that you refer to we haven't
seen that sort of
um reticence here and it is absolutely
vitally important as we come
up to the 12 week mark since margaret
keenan received her first jab on the 8th
of december
and so the number of people coming for a
second second jab
is going to start to rise as we go
through this month
and we've got all the supplies to
deliver that and everybody can have
confidence
that uh the uh the jab will be there
ready and waiting for them when they
go forward for their uh for their second
vaccination but obviously
coming forward for the uh for the uh the
second jab
is a very very important part of this
program because
while the first jab gives you this uh
this excellent protection that we're
seeing in the data that we're publishing
today
the data also show that for the pfizer
jab which is the only one
that we have the data for you get yet
further protection from the second jab
so um you should not just come forward
for the first job which people are doing
in
in droves and the numbers the uptake
figures are
spectacular but it is very important
that people come forward
for their second jab when they're asked
to as well
by the nhs anything you'd like to add
professor vantam thank you
um i'd just like to say that um
the the human immune system is really
incredibly complex and there are some
you know immunologists who are much
cleverer than i who are still
trying to get to the bottom of it and
probably the next generation of
immunologists after them will still be
trying to get to the bottom of it
but i think there's quite some
significant likelihood
that um a second dose of vaccine is
going to
mature your immune response possibly
make it broader
and almost certainly make it longer
than it would otherwise be in relation
to a first
dose only so whilst our policy is
absolutely and without apology or
reservation
being to pursue first dose is the
priority
for as many people as possible and
inevitably
the consequence of that is that the
second day
doses are delayed somewhat
it is absolutely critical that they are
still
part of the course of immunization
against covid19
and no less important for that reason
thanks very much thanks very much mesa
um the final question
is from jill lawless at ap jill
thank you very much um a question for
you uh the health
secretary um i wonder what you thought
about the eu's
plan uh for what they're calling a
digital vaccination
green pass essentially a vaccination
a vaccine passport um the uk's called
for international coordination on on
getting international travel going again
is that a useful idea and is it
something britain might want to sign up
to um and then
just one for everyone the um the roadmap
to easing the lockdown in england starts
in a week's time when uh
when children go back to class um and
then it proceeds in a
number of steps i wondered which step
you're the most concerned about
thanks very much jill so we are
absolutely working with our
international partners on
the any need for certification
in terms of having had a vaccine to be
able to travel to another country
because if another country wants to say
that you need to have been vaccinated
with a recognized vaccine to travel
there we want to enable
brits to be able to to take that journey
so we are working with international
partners and the eu is part of those
discussions
um as are several other
countries around the world and it's um
it's obviously important work and what
i'd also say is that in a sense
this already exists because you need to
have a test
before you can travel to the uk and as
far as i understand it from the
details set out today uh the eu proposal
is that it is
that certification includes both whether
you've had the vaccine and also whether
you've recently had a
test for those who can't get vaccinated
yet
um which is obviously uh particularly
important
um i i i i therefore it's
it's it's something that we're working
with them
and others on um and it matters that we
get the details of this right
for international travel and on the
question
on the roadmap um what i'd say in
response to your question
is that we have set out the tests
precisely so
we can be we can be sure
that the data still allow
for the safe step down
the road map and i'm highly confident
that the opening of schools on monday
is the right thing to do and the data
point that way and then we will assess
the data before taking
step two the the roadmap is designed
to be able to see the data before we
take each step
and so we've done it in that way in
order to
be able to have the assurance that we
are taking
a cautious yet irreversible path out of
this
pandemic dr hopkins anything to add on
that well
i would agree i think the thing that we
know is that children going back to
school and
each point is likely to increase
interactions with others
and therefore we are likely to see an
increase in the ore number
and potentially more transmissions what
we need to do is give time after each of
the
events to monitor the impact of that not
just on cases in the community
but particularly on hospital admissions
and deaths which is what
we see that the vaccines are preventing
and what will prevent
surges in hospitalizations and therefore
a big impact
so we'll need to monitor the cases after
each step and that's going to be really
important
thank you secretary of state at the risk
of sounding like a parrot
i'm not worried about any particular
step
i am far more worried that there is time
to consider the effect of each step
before we move on to the next one
and that way we get into a process
where we are hopefully with vaccines
relaxing in a very long-term way
and we don't have to go backwards and
forwards and backwards and forwards
in these kind of stuttering steps i'd
rather take
much slower and more pronounced and
measured steps
that always go in one direction and that
just means
moving a little more slowly than
sometimes
your instincts and your emotions and
your desires
um uh would lead you to want to do
there's one final point i'd like to make
on this uh joel which is the
the link to the data that we just
published on the vaccine efficacy
because the effectiveness of the vaccine
on protecting
people and on reducing transmission
is critical to the roadmap the only
reason we can set out
as full of roadmap as we have is because
of the vaccine rollout
because we know that without the vaccine
uh the uh
the the the the there is no way to keep
people safe in the way that we can with
the vaccine
and so the data that we've published
today
shows that the road map is
achievable because it shows that we will
be able
to break the link from cases through to
hospitalizations
and to deaths and until now in the
pandemic
that link from cases through to
hospitalizations and deaths has been
unbreakable and we have demonstrated
with the data today
that the vaccines can break that link
and that is down to the
power of science so it's good news for
everybody
and in in a way it it's reassuring
for our ability to progress down the
road map